on raconte que tu es le meilleur
guerrier du prince c'est faux alors
votre épouse vous a donné un beau garçon
c'est niet
c'est un grand honneur mon prince tout
l'honneur et pour moi
je sais ce qui t'es arrivé est ce qu'ils
demandent une rançon ou autre chose
ils veulent votre marre
que comptes tu faire
tu as donc une semaine pour retrouver ta
femme et ton fils et moi pour retrouver
la personne qui désire tant ma mort j'ai
fais serment devant toi dd liautaud bord
a retrouvé sa femme et son fils
ah ah
sur nos terres ton dieu est impuissant
tétouan est patent il s'est donc pas
reconnaître les bonnes personnes
des mauvaises
mon mari finira par vous retrouver
cette tour des pays
[Musique]
c'était un beau combat à venir